what's up everybody that day trashy tour
is rolling on coming down to the wire
few shows left uh it's a mix of standup
comedy ay me and the big man co-
headline then we come out close the
shows out together playing a with the
crowd get your tickies yeah the Cub lion
gang we coming to Minneapolis Minnesota
Madison Wisconsin Milwaukee Wisconsin
Sacramento California Sacramento
California again you got two shows there
scoop them up San Francisco California
San Jose Washington DC and then we're
closing out the year with two shows at
the Filmore in Philadelphia the 21st is
sold out get tickets for the 20th and
come see the boys do it welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you garbage oh yeah
it's that little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find out
that they get to be classy yeah to just
a big old piece of trash trash trash
trash I'm your host a fley coming at you
on a beautiful day we're out back here
at toties in a new edition she just hit
a billy goat with the car okay I don't
know what that goat was doing in the WWA
parking lot thought I'd shocky with that
one whatever my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me he's got his cool
new jean jacket on where's my camera the
cowboy over here give it up for the
Gambler Kevin James Ryan
everybody Let It Ride baby what's up
everybody thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate you subscribe
on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are T
Cook then obviously the greatest website
of all time you go over there you pull
your little computer you go
www.patreon.com
garbage check out the numbers over there
it's a gosh darn party gang yes sir and
have about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinary old magic man
works the ones and twos the threes and
the fours he crosses the teas and he
dots the eyes give it up for T-Bone MCC
scruffs Toby McMullan everybody what up
boys pal if my you know initial feelings
are correct I think we got a real
sweetie pie in the addition right now he
had yet Chicago what are you talking
where he Le in Chicago you leav in
Chicago in Chicago too I got to tell you
he's a tall drink of water and he smells
nice I'm man the most liberally perfumed
man to ever walk in here iy know I just
had to take a quick horse bath so you
can see if I'm actually
garbage had a couple clients there
wanted to freshen up for you guys gang
we couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest here with us today for the first
time he's a very funny standup comedian
and podcaster he's on tour right now he
is not one but two amazing podcasts the
social studies podcast and let's watch
TV and he's got a brand new special over
there on the YouTube that you got to
check out don't eat the Crayons give it
up for Joe D Browski everybody oh my God
good to see you P thanks for coming man
off the rip how do you pronounce that
word uh at the end of your special there
cray CR go it's messing everybody up
because that's when my Michigan accent
comes out it's crayons I really get him
on Bed Bath and Beyond Beyond yeah I'm
going down there to Bed Bath and Beyond
sounds like you're going down a slide
right right huh yeah crayons isn't good
well people some people say crayons
pronounce the Y crayons crayon I I mean
I say crowns this is well documented
which I know is wrong crayons is wrong
crowns is wrong crowns is for sure I
mean the the hate on crowns cray is in
is worse to me for sure what is that
cologne what's that scent you're you're
rocking it is well I won't say what the
brand is because you know I keep that to
myself La Lao labo Lao they have many
they have many different scents within
there and the one I wear is the rarest
okay and uh and you play that close to
the chest I just say lbo and then people
are like I'll figure it out I'm like
yeah good try you won't you won't one
fan comment is oh my God you smell so
good you do smell you smell nice smell
good man you thank you give us the uh
give us the origin story of Joe jamb
Browski what's the what's the backstory
um born a poor little school girl in
Detroit I know came up in Detroit uh was
a a elementary school teacher for 10
years doing comedy really yeah on the
off time because I don't know if you
guys know teachers are um uh poor people
so I had I'm not really rolling in it
doing spots for gas money you know
trying to make it happen then that [__]
blew up and now I'm on are you garbage
there you go [__] love that baby um
what was the mom and dad brother sister
situation suburb child super shocking
yeah really freak Show all right no
stranger to
attention chist Imaginary Friends
growing up uh question is how many is
actually basketball team like my dog I
would convince people that my my golden
retriever was my brother then they'd
come over and be Marshall
oh where is Marshall I'm like oh he's
under the table he's licking licking his
ass in his
rooms [__] and what your mom and dad do
uh my dad was a civil engineer for Air
Force Base okay and my mom is a nurse
okay some learned people there yeah all
over the place she did everything uh
from hospice to whatever it's called
what's a vagina doctor a gy OBGYN yeah
an OBGYN there we go hospice nurses man
I have limited knowledge so hospice
nerves is a different breed that's a
that's a tough gig it is it is for sure
they're on point too they really are
she's quick she's quick brings them up
when they're down they're down a lot in
hosp they're down all very suffocates
them with a pillow when they're on their
way out H how are the grades yeah oh
terrible really oh horrible horrible I
couldn't read till I was in thirdd grade
what why couldn't read till I was in
third grade third grade changed my life
cuz I went to Catholic school never
heard that sentence before third grade
didn't it changed my life I went to
Catholic School up until third grade and
I was just so dumb that they swept me
under the T I had like weeks in the coat
closet foreshadowing but they just
didn't care about me so just threw me in
there when I went to public school in
third grade and my teacher was like so
your kid can't
read he new Flash do couple of things
but she was so cool cuz she let me like
express my learning instead of just like
writing a a book report she was like
yeah act it out act it out in front of
everybody and I was like hell yeah and
that's how I kind of godamn here's Jo
literally literally this [__]
[__] reenacting the
hob it's like can I get a suggestion
from the class what do you do for a
living sir he just up there doing crowd
work exactly but I was a stand-up
comedian in third grade too for the
talent show my teacher was my teacher
threw me in she's like give this a shot
did you write your own material or did I
stole them from magician at my conf my
first yeah yeah it was crazy but wait
you had a magician at your first
communion party yeah there's parts of me
that are not garbage and that's one of
them you know what nuts you the civil
engineer and the nurse that's classy
magician at your birthday party nobody
had a First Comm so you think it's
classy that you had a First Holy
Communion party I do because I think my
parents were just like envious of Barm
mitz was so they're like do everybody
had one of the only problem with the
communion was you didn't get any cash
like the bar mitzvah kids did Mitzvah
kids made a lot of cash you remember
what you pulled in from that communion
party I'm going to say like a couple
hundred for sure sure all went to the
magician I know the overhead was real
high yeah for sure do you remember some
of the bits that you stole from the mag
from said said magician yeah for sure I
I said um who who out here likes candy
ice cream big fat spankings I was
like man little racy for third grade
some of it was a little racy but it was
198 the Titanic just came out you guys
saw Rose's titties they were horrible um
okay okay huh what was what was the
house like growing up Sing Sing family
apartment sing family home Ranch suburbs
of Detroit big backyard that backed up
to a farm not our farm sure but you you
get the view of the farm you get the
view of the farm were you allowed to go
on the Farm property no right did we yes
those Farmers don't like did they tell
you there was a guy with a shotgun that
would shoot you my used to tell me that
Chucky was running around in the field
and that would always get me to come
back the doll yeah the doll damn yeah
they're the same people who would tell
me that there were sharks in the lake to
get me not to swim like we like thrived
on lies cuz let's be real I wasn't
listening to the rules yeah that's good
those dumbrowski are [__] twisted
people tell you [__] Chucky the devil
owns that farm Jesus Christ and also
lives in your basement just wanted some
blueberry try a cup of decaf and Cheryl
okay a right your dad wasn't in the
military though right he was in the Navy
for a while okay and then he he worked
on a he worked on a sub he worked on a
sub he worked on a sub as an electrician
he was a CB and then um like he was CB
he was a CB that's [__] awesome yeah
he was a CB and they go in and they
build the air strips and [__] like that
I know what a CB does no you don't yeah
so then now we're in our new house too
right we have to do a bunch of
electrical I tell my fans I go I'll just
call my dad and he's like oh no no no
I'm like my dad was a civil engineer on
a sub he'll redo this whole house
they'll have more light switches than we
need sure two torpedo tubes in the front
yard turn your key Joe turn your key
everything's everything's red lights
100% everybody's sweaty you look into
the chimney it's a periscope the
lighting sucks but it's waterproof as
[__] for sure for sure um so you're
saying the grades weren't good terrible
they were terrible where'd you go to
college Central Michigan University and
then I got my masters at Oakland
University you have your Masters in what
I have my Master's in Elementary
Administration okay yeah so I could be
an elementary school principal at any
given moment right now yeah they're
going to watch this fashion then that'll
definitely not be true anymore did you
take the SATs I did I did terrible I
don't remember the number but I remember
being shocked that I got into to college
even was it over a thousand I don't even
know how they were what is it it depends
well how old how old of a gentleman are
you I'm 34 okay so you probably took oh
I don't know no might have switched
right then I think I did the Act only
yeah that makes sense yeah yeah yeah one
of those one of Midwest is acts I think
didn't do great but went to Central
which is also in the middle of a
cornfield and was surrounded by a bunch
of other [__] Chucky ran that yeah a
in beer bonging so hey okay out do it
and he Sports as a kid yeah um ribbon
dancing and skip it where the preferred
um you say skip it that thing you put on
your ankle
yeah you're familiar almost went pro mhm
it was really good Olympics Olympics did
you really do ribbon dancing I I mean
like in the so here's the other thing
recreationally he wasn't in the Olympics
you know outside of being a civil
engineer r d Browski was a DJ in the 90s
so he would bring out his DJ equipment
and just like play it in the backyard
and I was just like fancily doing my
thing to jock jams in the background Jo
James by the way had to be the backyard
cuz he's like this [__] ain't going to
the front yard sure I don't want someone
stealing my
turntables did your dad DJ events at all
or just like yeah oh yeah did he do the
Holy Communion party yes of course he
saved saved money on that char did he
did he have a DJ name like Admiral Vibes
or something Ronnie D R pretty good DJ
Ronnie D can get the energy up at a
party he sure could okay listen to this
[__] though one time '90s SEL my heart
will come on or go on was the height
right it's being suggested cuz my dad
was doing a daddy daughter dance and I
went as his like little dj sidekick and
I was like Dad I'm GNA sing it for them
and he's like uh okay here's the mic
he's like go under the table and I'll
put your mic on so like they don't know
where the sound is coming from he cuts
the
mic I come out like this I think it's I
think it's off can you hear me in the
back it's a goddamn paid gig I know I
was Selen di sure
sure I'm sure they had a couple
questions why there was a young boy
underneath the DJ booth there's no
questions we everyone was aware uh are
they still in that same house you grew
up in or no yes they are are without
giving away the name of the street what
was it like uh Street Avenue Terrace
Circle it was a street it was a
full-blown subdivision houses on houses
the neighborhood that I grew up in is
houses strip malls churches schools sure
that's that's most of America we've come
to we've come to the conclusion people
picture what most of America looks like
that was yeah what was the name of the
pizza place you guys would frequent as a
child this is a Hot Topic Detroit style
pizza is a big deal sure I never got it
love it there's this one pizza that I'm
I like runs through my veins it's called
Jets Pizza I talk about them publicly so
much and the fact that I have not gotten
even the slightest sponsorship makes my
blood boil so I've actually Swit slice
yeah so uh Buddy's Pizza is my new faite
so you flipped on Jets cuz they're not
giving you any La that's Jets Pizza I
it's so good that looks pretty good
people were messaging me telling me they
were doing like Harold and Kumar Go to
White Castle road trips to get jets cuz
I talk about it like this isn't I put me
in a commercial at the very least Jets
Detroit style pizza is fantastic I grew
up in uh for up until fourth grade in
upstate Pennsylvania and we had
something called Sizzle Pie which is
very similar to Detroit style pizza they
just don't put the cheese around the
outside
so it's like that it's like fried a
little bit because they put the oil in
the pan yeah you got to get that crispy
crust there was no round pie it was all
it was all square always Square always
Square always crunchy yeah that's all
right man shout out to Jets I'm not a
ranch on pizza guy but Jets is
particularly good with ranch you know
Jets you had Jets no no no you go to
jets for the pizza you come back for the
ranch it's thick as how it'll clog your
arteries it's the best it's like Midwest
Ambrosia oh they do is it a chain it is
a chain gotcha but it's like
not to smaller chain oh oh I'll say I
watched it go from not a chain to a
chain gotcha in my generation I mean
they're doing 510 million US dollars in
2022 it's all Ranch those guys are those
500 million 500 million in ranch I go
you order the ranch by the bottle you
don't ask for a side really yeah oh yeah
really that's pretty trashy when they
when they're putting the ranch forward
ohy it's pizza made for Duncan yeah
100 I love you
I knew you were a sweetie pie I love you
oh my God I love you you ever dip your
crust in soda I'm sorry what Toby cut
that yeah that's I mean we got to dude
you can't just be coming up with ones
like that you got to bounce those off I
did that when I was a kid I used to do
that and I would take the cheese off and
eat the cheese by itself and then eat
the eat the slice of pizza I like to
watch him french onion soup Jesus Christ
man you get me a french onion woo I love
that's like a ball of gum I used to love
it crushing that mozzarella
so good so good H okay what was uh the
grocery store going up growing up Kroger
krer respectable it's a good Kroger uh
Christmas always big deal lots of lights
all over the house white colored what'
you use colored and white doubled up
[__] new school old school real tree
always every year all right what were
the uh family vacations looking like uh
Disney World we weren't a Myrtle Beach
family we weren't like that garbage but
we went yeah we went to Disney World
Drive no fly Drive no from Michigan
that's a hump yeah where is the normal
uh vacation destination for Detroit
family yeah Myrtle Beach it would be huh
and everybody would drive yeah everybody
would drive I've never been to Myrtle
Beach I did do a show in like around the
area and I'm like I I don't think I'm I
don't think I missed anything sure
Myrtle Beach is rough I went for a
spring break one
year I drove down B my mom's car with
like four of my buddies God damn it was
rough no shade to Myrtle Beach but like
I'm not going yeah it's tough it was
like very I remember there was just
girls flat there was there was like a
bead economy like Marty Gro type thing
oh so you would just go beads and just
be like you know and come back with like
a sea turtle even
sure it's [__] it's a it's a good
time down there you said real tree
always always even today okay all right
I respect it what was uh the high school
mascot growing up an eagle that's pretty
good not and the question is was I the
eagle I you were the mascot I was the
eagle many many times I'll tell you what
you get a good scholarship doing that
[__] CU a lot of people don't do it and
a buddy of mine ended up going to I want
to say Michigan or something like that
on like a full ride to be the mascot and
then got a job with the Rockets I got to
say k it that the most dir hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year that's it
every time any dirt bag's watching a
football game or a basketball game and
they cut to the mascot someone goes you
know how much they make 200
I know I'm not saying it's not but that
is great it's also a great way to get
lice
actually you had lice in high school
dude I'm like from the mascot it was
insane it was insane you know how you
get lice out yeah I had it twice twice
yeah as a little kid not in high school
I'm not a he did it just for the
mayonnaise ma you're never going to
believe this I got lice give me a tuna
Hogie
no I had it twice my mom would use the
comb oh and just [__] rip our hair
out and then Buzz our hair eventually
which I don't know why she didn't just
skipped that step I think she enjoyed it
K let's talk about Helix shout out the
Helix baby Best In The Biz we're all on
the team over there at Helix big Helix
guy yeah gang do yourself a favor get
over to Helix take the take the
two-minute quiz find out how you like to
sleep choose between 20 different
options including their
awardwinning Lux collection and brand
new Helix Elite collection I'm an elite
man myself don't be slipping man I'll
tell you that right now you'll be
sleeping sound this holiday season all
the way true to New Year yeah don't let
these fancy names overwhel you overwhelm
you just take the quick quiz to the
website and see what match is best for
you I've been saying it once I've been
saying it twice I'm a goddamn Helix man
took the quiz first one we got was the
Twilight now I got the new house I'm
putting helixes in everywhere baby you
get a helix you get a helix they got
that quiz unlocked too do you sleep on
your side do you sleep on your back are
you a big guy you a small guy m M what
do you like uh a lot of other mattress
Brands put fiberglass in their products
which obviously ain't great for
breathing all night long you won
sleeping on a Mountain Dew bottle you
won't find any of that with Helix just
the best sleep you've ever had and the
most comfortable mattress you've ever
owned and that's a that's a Kippy
guarantee that's a fulley guarantee as
well stop stealing my guarantees Helix
is offering 25% off double guarantee
Helix is offer take that to the bank
Helix is offering 25 shut up while I'm
doing the the stuff I got to hit
verbatim Helix is offering 25% off all
mattress orders and a free sleep bundle
for are you garbage listeners in honor
of Black Friday the bundle includes two
free pillows as well as a set of sheets
and even a mattress protector go to
helixsleep.com
garbage and use the code Helix partner2
this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
star now do it do it this episode is
brought to you by betterhelp gang the
holiday season you know what comes with
that the blues the holiday blues if
you're feeling down don't hold it all in
get it out reach out to better help they
can actually help you if you can't find
a specialist in your area they got you
covered man you could do it from the
privacy of your own home you don't got
to wait in the doctor's office like
you're getting a haircut or something
like that yeah uh like I I've said it i'
for years a big proponent of uh this
guy's screw balls big proponent of talk
therapy it helps you out you can use it
for short periods of your life job stuff
relationship stuff family stuff just to
get through and maybe it's the tool that
you use ongoing forever it's great talk
to somebody you go to the gym to get
your muscles talk to someone get your
brain muscles know I do uh as much as
you might love chatting with your
friends or significant other reaching
out to a trained therapist is a total
game changer for your mental health it
really is find your bright spot this
season with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com garbage today to get 10%
off your first month that's better help
hp.com garbage do it gang okay got life
as a teacher once too that really lice
ring worm all all of it dude where the
[__] are you teaching
Pontiac
Michigan shout out to Pontiac the
Crowfoot Ballroom in Pontiac Michigan
hey look at you lice is an adult that's
a tough look how about the pets what was
the pets any birds any snakes any
Turtles uh so the I'm an animal lover
right we were a golden retriever family
through right still have I got my little
boy Marshall was growing up he was the
rid gold retriever family as well oh
okay well here you go just so you can
see this guy looks like he should be on
an bean I turned it off I'll show real
true I'm a good I'm a good a true bro so
um but then I would sneak animals in cuz
like I so we had like a box turtle that
I wasn't allowed to have that I acquired
okay I did have a couple snakes lots of
frogs you find in these tadp the most of
the frogs and snakes yes I did purchase
the box turtle where would you keep the
frogs and like a fish tank yeah yeah
yeah yeah in my bedroom my were they
like those tree frogs like neon green
ones that would stick to the wall frog
were big I had a frogs toads you name I
was just really into that [__] I used to
like frogs as a kid too yeah yeah yeah
they're cool oh did
you that's a that's a guy trying to get
in on a conversation I also I like frogs
too guys I know what you guys are
talking about full-blown Weirdo And then
I worked at the Detroit Zoo as one of my
side jobs while I was teaching and with
the amphibian were you there too I was
the director of kindergarten summer camp
that's pretty cool pretty cool yeah
until a zookeeper took some of the
kindergarteners in the python habitat
that happened yikes that was cool great
Jam me up a little bit yeah made the
worst I've ever sweat was that day J
playing it fast and loose in Detroit yes
yeah I mean the Detroit Zoo yikes it's a
great Zoo they just said they were
putting kids in the python C I mean not
intentionally it's just you need to drug
test the key first
more all right um refrigerator in the
garage uh not us but the neighbors all
of them yeah okay hm all right what was
uh what was the first job growing up
well my first job I worked at a dry
cleaner really worked at a dry cleaner
yeah strange yeah how old were you it
was very strange 15 no kidding were you
the one actually doing the dry cleaning
or working the front yeah they gave me
like way too much responsibility I was
doing the front the cash register I was
closing I had a key I'm taking the
that's crazy a 15-year-old with a key to
a business I'm taking the stuff down
giving it to them like touching base
like the two women who were like the
presser and the washer like they were
just like okay this is how you do it if
forever not here just BL I'm like I'm
not even in a union I could steam off my
hands not even in a union man that's
some real Detroit [__] I ain't even in
the local and you got me out here
working like a scy got no benefits I'll
have to rat out here in two three days I
tell you shake this place down that's
old school [__] steel [__] UAW does
have a dry cleaning division that I
should have been a part of family
dinners at the house would you eat
dinner as a family every night always
every night every night cooked my mom
cooked yes she was doing the cooking she
was she what's her real what's one real
good dish You' you get so my dad's
polish that's the dbr my mom's Italian
Fano so like the Lasagna were on point
sauce no can sauce can touch it she
still hates if I buy any sort of canned
sauce really what are you doing if you
do do a jar sauce what are you going
with uh you got to doctor it up you
can't just take a jar sauce so we will
do like a uh
usually how do you guys say it say
itos
she doesn't know how to say it I said
Rouse forever forever The Duality of
trash over here but you could take
sounds like something at PF Changs give
it a rouse you could take a a preo as
long as you're like gonna like Sizzle up
your own meat with Italian seasoning I
used to love back in the day yeah yeah
yeah you can't just take straight up jar
sauce unless it's R Rous if you made
pasta at the house for you and your
fiance would you do the whole whole jar
and the whole box I mean we're two guys
sure so we're we're eating I respect it
I respect it um what was the perogi
situation that was polish high and
mighty lots of Perogies yeah sauté the
onions uh Bacon Fat onions yeah little
sour cream sour cream usually a side of
sourkraut definitely some kabasa smoked
and regular it's all right my book I
tell
that we wrap this up right now you had
me a parois right it was very pul
okay what was uh what was the first
concert Hansen all right that's of the
time I can't hate on my parents were
literally like don't take your Ribbon or
your skiet so went to handsome with the
neighbors it was great okay with the
neighbors with the neighbor kids yeah
okay all right all right bad was it the
height of Hansen height of I tell you
what it's not a bad hot track it's hot
have you looked at Hansen recently
though they look like youth pastors nuts
it's nuts yeah what about snacks in a
room were you allowed to eat in your
room no no eatting room no no no how are
the snacks at the house do you have like
cookies and candies and chips or was it
a pretty tight ship yeah yeah we were
the house where the friends came to eat
love that sugar cereal in the morning
yeah any cereal in the morning yeah I I
remember I look back at this now if I
had oatmeal in the morning there was
like a side of brown sugar to go with it
just like I which I let's be ready hold
Michigan mornings my ADHD ass did not
need any sugar go sure sure I remember
being like I won't eat brown sugar cuz
it's too healthy which is insane that
was SP I'm like give me the white [__] I
don't I don't need this health sugar it
was just always so [__] up in our
house cuz it was like we got one bag in
like 1978 she never used it so it was
all rocks it was pack yeah dude it was
packed like [__] black heart
heroin it was that [__] was like a
kilo how do you get your steak cooked
medium rare gentle on the rare side you
like meatloaf love meatloaf all right
the band just the
the okay I got one for you yeah are you
a t pick one of the three tji Fridays
Applebees or Olive Garden I don't do a
chain really I don't do a chain thanks
for coming by
Jo what the special Toby turn these
cameras off I have so many Homeland
Security show you out I have so many
friends who crave those places I don't
yeah they're called Americans I don't
there's something about godamn fathers a
CB pie back like that think he was
working on a submarine so you could eat
a local joint there's something about
knowing that that soup came from a bag
and was just like put in a pot and now
it's done I you're not wrong it did the
the Tik Tok everybody filming themselves
it has ruined it a little bit I can
remove myself from it but you're not
wrong I I do understand that yeah to
know like everything's just heated in a
bag yeah I'm so sorry that's that's my
hard line I love it if there was a
special occasion and then NE Browski
were going out to dinner where would
your mom and dad take you Louis Chop
House shout out toou hey he hey there
was only one kid yeah oh ah so you got a
little more bang for your Bock I'm not
saying we were loaded I'm just saying
there was only one I like that is that a
chain Louis Chop House no it's just a
Detroit Detroit that sounds awesome yeah
it's good as [__] classy long running
restaurant offering steak a lounge with
craft cocktails and live piano music
years in a Mak looks all right I bet
they do a baked potato that'll blow your
sock doesn't come when they watch this
I'm going to shout out to Lou Chop
House all right huh all right got check
out this menu real
quick I did I like had crab legs when I
was probably like seven really pretty
good when didd you get your passport uh
18 I didn't leave the country for the
first time until then probably go the
first time I left Canada that's where
you go when you turn 181 19 so you keep
drinking go yeah okay Windsor any TV
shows that you watch together as a
family growing up uh this is insane um
Flavor of Love really in high school we
watch Flavor of Love together your
parents watch Flavor of Love with me I
remember Tiffany Pard New York and the
original Seas shout out to New York I
watched almost all of her spin-off shows
too New York was a character oh I'm not
going to sit here and say I didn't watch
the program just didn't watch it with my
parents oh yeah we were down as a family
watching this happen with FL Flav
spitting in pumpkin's face like these
iconic cult moments yeah for sure for
sure she just had it out with Amarosa I
saw that I I keep I keep I follow New
York you're an
ally catch him at the next New York City
Pride Parade everyone love it I'm the
Grand Marshall out there it's me in New
York okay H interesting if you get
takeout food will you plate the takeout
food or do you eat out of the container
it came in Morgan always Morgan's my
fiance I thought it was the dog Morgan
and Marshall best friends running around
in the field he'll play it I don't plate
it I can eat it right out of there then
close it put it in the fridge and come
back to it later he plates it it does
make you I feel fancy when I plate it
even if it's like a slice of pizza or
something I'm like I feel a little
elevated no need to Plate it I'm all
about doing less dishes I I don't know
why but I can picture you in like a
three-piece suit at a McDonald's at like
2 a.m. just like really I think I need
to leave now after that
saying stuff like I can't believe I'm
here right
now are we at
McDonald's do you own a suit yeah I do
how many two what we name brand what do
we got I don't know I bought I bought
them in Australia they look great so I
got them Australian on my Australian
tour that was incredible they're all
made of armadillos
theyers they were I kept putting them on
they're like you American why are you
wearing it so baggy and they're like let
us do this for you and I was like okay
put these [__] on I'm like God
damnn I have an ass you you got a frame
for a suit you do drink of water let's
just I do can you tie a tie absolutely a
couple different ways really what what
are your peeve what are your go-to knots
oh can can we talk about what my go- to
notnot is I'm in do you know when guys
tie the tie wrong and it's like a
triangle that's like slanted to one
side we got to step it up we got to step
it up I know I I only know the one way I
think it's called the Pratt my under
part is is always like a little tongue
it never goes all the way down or
sometimes it's longer and I just stick
it in I stick it in my shirt I I had
this one this one teacher that I worked
with he looked at me and he was like
that's suit we got to learn how to tail
your suits as like look at your tie
first of all do not [__] with a game man
scoring right now on this day in this
suit not me huh you wear suits to work
no but like every once in a while you'd
have to like for parent teacher
conferences are open house or something
special like that kids are getting
Awards that's like do you uh do you get
the eyebrows done you get the eyebrows
waxed or shaped or anything not often
but when they get out of control you got
to you got to make them make them good
Manny petties yeah okay yeah that's
that's my number one thing to do on
those Road weekends get too much time on
your hands you go get them man your
petty you do a massage too all three
let's do it I respect it always clear
clear mat nothing crazy just a clear
finish you get a finish yeah baby g y
hello I've been tempted I've been
tempted when I get my cuz I got a
pedicure for uh for bird screw for BT
crw and they're do you want a little
color I was going to get them painted
but then I was like then then do you
want the clear color I was like nah just
don't want my going have to put a set of
primer on that before they paint those
yellow JN you got that there here Jesus
Christ go for it go for it just tell
them clear matte if you want to get
crazy a clear matte gel it'll last
longer okay all right I respect it
pretty classy so far I gotta be honest
with you that's I'm surprised he did
have a magician at his his dad was a DJ
like did you collect anything growing up
oh I think I was just like a little
packrat so the question is what didn't I
collect Beanie Babies absolutely we
sold kid uh not so much Beanie Babies
hardcore my mom sold beanie babies out
of our garage we bought them in bulk
like people were coming over to buy
Beanie Babies out of the garage running
a little black market Beanie Baby
situation make some money off of it
esecially esecially that's how you say
it when you have a stroke um especially
Princess Diana be a baby we had like 10
of them and people were going ner they
were hot going nerds what uh on the on
the topic of of grooming what uh what
are you paying for who's cutting your
hair what are you paying for it what are
you tipping uh I just got my haircut
here in New York cuz you cannot get that
East Coast fade in Seattle so I I needed
it he went a little short on the top
hence the hat today and uh I'm a very
generous Tipper yeah me too it feels
nice now you can do it on things that
deserve the tip right like I I drink my
coffee black the end so if you're going
to just turn around pour it and give it
to me I'm so sorry I'm not I'm not B I
respect it but like at the clubs like
I'm very good to the people in the room
I'm very good to the sound like all of
it and uh when it comes to a haircut if
I W you're getting a tip regardless but
if I walk out and that fade is fresh o
maybe even 100% sometimes how much was
that cut 40 Buck cut that's that's
that's Manhattan that's par for the
course 40 Buck cut and I loved it and I
G like this fade that's tight yeah damn
I gave him a 20 down at a bone yeah bad
uh will you split the
check you go never never if you go out
to eat with like some of your friends
you pick it up this time never yeah
never no I don't I don't like that whole
fiddle fatle at the end I don't like
great word for it the fiddle fadle I
don't like giving the server more work I
don't like having to settle up on venmo
after none of that I got it we we're
going to go out again trust me all good
and then um yeah with Morgan too it's
the same thing one of us has got it and
it's never been an issue since our first
date nice yeah will you send a venmo
request to anybody
um I would never send a venmo request
okay I would never send a venmo request
hey you owe me 40 bucks for that
whatever but if later they're like oh
hey like can I see your VMO just when
you can settle up then I'll be like sure
but I'm never going to like do dot okay
with this is gentleman he's a gentleman
all right with dating men your fiance
included in this how do you decide in
those first initial dates who's picking
up the check well it depends who has the
stronger lisp first of
all that's all right kid's
quick I don't know with Morgan and I
would just kind
of first of all it couldn't have picked
a better person with this crazy comedy
life he's so supportive and so great and
even with that we always were just so
even ke with each other we're just like
you me you me like it just was never an
issue what does Morgan do can we ask we
can't he's a big wig for a
thing a big wig for a thing so when I
when I um I love that when I that's the
classy answer when we moved to se it it
was at a time where I could tour so I
was like let's go and you conquer your
dreams I'll live wherever I can tour
that's pretty good there's a lot of biz
out there in Seattle I like it very
proud he he killed it he killed it he's
doing great what do you guys live in now
do you have an apartment or a house we
live in a house you live in a house do
you guys own it or you're renting it we
own it all right here we go nice joint I
assume can I come
over yeah you can is Morgan packing what
are we talking about what's the heat
situation he got a pool you have a pool
we don't have a pool no pools big out
there there I don't know like some
regionally it does don't always hit no
no no not thing no hot tub Morgan would
love a hot tub I think hot tubs are PE
soup sure it's a good way to put it yeah
all right king-sized bed at the house
yes absolutely how many pillows on the
bed there is about oh [__] 10 10 pillows
did they get taken off when you guys go
to bed at night I use all my five you do
run that down yeah break that down I use
all my five so I do two behind my head
one between my legs I'm hugging one so
now that's five yeah I love it that's
the way I sleep too are you sleeping
away or you sleeping in oh this is the
other thing too we Morgan and I have NE
we are like sleep is important get your
own [__] space like fre like do your
thing on your side and stay there I
respect it uh TV on when you go to bed
no TV in the bedroom no TV in the are
you reading it these are learned people
listen he's the guy's got a job he can't
talk about think he's watching TV had if
I had it my way we'd have two TVs in
there Morgan is not letting it happen
he's a cutro businessman he's not having
it he can't be watching the prices right
going to bed he's not having it there's
no TV allowed so I will just like flip
on my iPad and watch something put my
headphones in okay or read or read I
read a lot of Comedy stuff so really
yeah yeah is Morgan a reader too he is
yeah so you guys sitting in bed before
you go to bed reading no never never
really like that usually like one of us
might like pick up a book for a couple
weeks and but mainly we're just watching
[__] our own [__] you're showering at
night or showering in the morning oh I
shower frequently so sometimes both but
always at night I always at night always
at night and it's like I'm going to do
another one in the morning most like I
would I like I'm not going to go out
somewhere and not shower in the morning
but if I'm home Monday through Wednesday
before I go on the road those days I'll
only shower at night but when I'm on the
road up do it get it going yeah okay you
know how you got to get keep your
routine going I'm with it baby I'm with
it speaking routine any moisture any
face moisturizer serums anything like
that all of them the whole yeah yeah the
under eye patches the caffeinated rubs
all of it we I'm not going to age like
cottage cheese I know teaching alone
will do that to you I felt that I I felt
like that was a attack at me when you
looked at me I'm not going to age like
cottage cheese I can feel the bags under
my eyes growing Kevin breon's over here
list one year of teaching will agid you
so fast you'll go in you'll look like a
fresh face 22y old you and then you walk
out that same year looking
crread with a melted candle it's
terrible let's talk about Aura shout out
to Aura baby if you're missing family
and friends we got the cura and it's
called Aura boom put that in the bank
yeah there you go gang with free
unlimited storage you can send as many
photos to the frame as you want and
allow an unlimited number of people to
send their pictures to you so you got
the frame all right we got ours on the
uh where what's called you cook the
countertop okay all right got it in the
oven her family in Hawaii uploads
pictures of the kids they come in fresh
oh look there's a little guy yeah you
get to stay connected dude they're
fantastic Patty's got one we got one
everybody's got one sent us like 40 of
them sent my mom a dickpic last week
yikes that was an awkward call from now
on through Black Friday and Cyber Monday
Aura is offering their best deal of the
Year listeners can save on the perfect
gift by visiting Ora frames.com garbage
that's Ora frames a a frames.com garbage
use promo code garbage to get $40 off
their best selling frames terms and
conditions apply do it game what about
um have you guys had any weddings
recently we're about to have our own ah
of course yeah yeah we're getting
married this Summer congratulations any
guests at any weddings recently uh wait
have we like we been guest have you guys
gone to weddings we deny a lot of
weddings do yeah because we so Morgan's
uh southern guy I'm from Michigan so
we're really far away so I'm on the road
every weekend so it's we don't get to go
do you send a gift in your it depends
who it is love that depends who it is
are you sending cash or do you guys get
a nice gift um again depends who it is
yeah if it's someone that's like really
important to us will probably figure out
something unique and special that they
like and get that to Morgan and his
entire family the most thoughtful gift
givers it's insane really his mom got me
a Christmas present before I'm super
into Pottery she went out and found this
one specific pottery place also not
you're
like but she found this specific artist
and like got this limited edition thing
that they only put out on their email
blast damn and then got it and I opened
it up for Christmas and I was like the
amount of time that she listened to me
talk about this once kept it in the back
of her head and Morgan's the same way
they're the most kindest people these
guys are on point I like it how do you
feel about the RO tiser chicken Morgan's
obsessed there's always one in the
fridge I can't do it anymore cuz he's a
creature of habit we constantly got the
rotisserie chick but now I'm accepting
his differences and figuring out recipes
rather than just having rotisserie
chicken turn it into a lot you cook at
the house a lot oh yeah all the time
both of us but like one of the first
weeks we met we cooked together it was
great yeah can I just say
congratulations this Morgan sounds like
a real dream I got to tell you he's
perfect something else he's hot as [__]
there you go I'm going to need to see a
picture just say well when I turn my
phone on I'll show you our dog and my
Mario save the dog folks folks we'll be
we'll be right back let me see let me
see that Morgan of yours he's good at
everything and so goodlooking next to
him I'm just like I'm just this tall
troll okay it's great how's the
furniture at the house highend stuff
westm it's it's very Restoration
Hardware very RH is expensive that it it
looks good how about the cookery you got
any lacus Sal whatever it's called
couple pieces CLE color talking because
because I cook I cook in them a lot I do
a lot of sauces in there I do a lot of
like brazed things and I I I really
appreciate the quality of that I got a
red one and a blue one shout out to it
and for Christmas I asked Morgan for
like this big round white one so I could
do a whole chicken like Dutch oven style
type nice where you shopping where you
clothes shopping what what's what that
shirt targeted ad I think this is
actually this do you guys ever do
Vermont comedy club no Burlington was
beep bopping around in Burlington
stopped in this little shop yeah just
like a little local joint bought this
love it but most of the [__] I buy is a
targeted ad no kidding yeah I don't even
you a scotch and soda guy yeah yeah
yeah they put their [__] that's also
not targeted ad it's like a famous store
for like 20 years they'll Target you um
Oh I thought you were asking about the
drink I was like dudee B on the fritz
bro straight straight straight person
yeah it's not a Guns and Roses t-shirt
nobody doesn't know what it is the thing
I don't like about scotch and soda is
they put [__] cologne on all their
clothes so it it never comes out no it's
not good I have a shirt there from like
5 years ago it still smells like a
French [__] smells like Joe every time
I put it
on you're welcome
[__] what kind of car you
whipping around in Joe nothing crazy I
okay first of all from Detroit and yeah
but it's you
um gross I cannot drive a foreign car
being from Detroit it's like in my blood
it's like the big three the end Morgan
keeps pushing the limits and I'm like
absolutely not for bust and I will drive
a car till it's done so uh
2017 um Ford Escape nothing crazy it's
got some dings it's got some Nicks it
needs some help but it's moving and I
just don't [__] care Amer and that's
it he does what's he whipping uh a a fun
one it's a fun car sure yeah yeah it's a
fun car it's just a Mustang it's all
right nothing for hey it's Ford we're
Ford on Ford for sure any cat machines
at the house oh God damn I couldn't do
it do I have um sleep AC for sure I'll
choke if my sleep on the rag but it it
you can't who can sleep in it he does
love I couldn't even get through the
trial and I took it back and I said you
can all [__] yourselves I can't even
sleep I got a I must have a great one
the nose or the whole face nose really
yeah nose and your mustache doesn't
interfere with that uh it's really soft
I actually I love the sound of it it
puts me right to sleep I feel like I'm
sleeping on a spaceship and you can
sleep on your back now totally fine I
sleep on my side even with it on yeah
now what about the side of your head
doesn't he get I'm telling you I don't
know what everybody's talking about it
it it's it's super comfy mine's super
flexible it's there's no really hard
plastic I can't sleep with my face he
can also put up with a lot his
discomfort level is high higher
tolerance than most people I'm sitting
on a nail right
now been there
um yeah yeah yeah couldn't do it could
do it okay all right have you ever skied
in jeans no can you ski yes can you surf
no do you own skis no
have you ever snowboarded uh yeah too
straight okay if you were with somebody
and they had a booger or bad breath
would you give my heads up uh politely
when we're by ourselves not bad breath
probably though really yeah that that I
might just like put gum in and like see
if they ask sure but like a Bogue for
sure I'd be like he yeah one of these
bat in the cave they keep the box of
things like if you get a new iPhone God
I'm a box hoarder it's just recently I
bro broke that habit of like all Apple
product boxes you can like they make
them to feel like it's better than the
the bag you get it in even better know
the suction like the do you remember
when the bag that they used to give it
in was actually like a a drawring
backpack pretty much yeah couldn't get
rid of that I used to hate those
drawring that was that was younger
Generations those backpacks sucked with
just the strings and the back they
started for like sports the napsack the
the drawring thing I never had one okay
uh have you been a to a TJ Maxx in the
last 30 days I have not okay will you
will you go to one if they target me on
Instagram probably okay H all right in
the shower you peeing in the shower um
not often but sometimes it has to happen
brush your teeth in there no electric
toothbrush regular toothbrush electric
flossing every day how many times three
four every time after I eat yeah okay my
dentist straight up says I'm the poster
child for flossing H braces when you
were a kid yes nice okay big old Gap in
between those two fronnies what is the
toothpaste Crest 3D whitening mhm Arctic
mint will you get the burger at a
Mexican
restaurant probably okay it's good to
know probably just for future dating
purposes proba case thing with Morgan
don't work out uh take a swing at the
kid so pretty serious with you so pretty
serious with you and your husband who
you own a house with I I I always say
that the the the burger in the Mexican
restaurant is a very underrated item on
their menu it's usually unbelievable got
a couple jalapenos on it nice mm I I
respect that uh what kind of soap are
you using in a shower uh Dr Squatch
coconut something very nice you take
that on the road with you God yes
absolutely see I hate we're I'm on the
road so much that if I don't have my
products it's just my body will freak
out if I don't take my face stuff like
my own face wash I'll break out like 3
days later I'm like I have to have it
sometimes when you get when you're in a
hotel they have the dispenser of the
body wash use you'll use that I will
I'll use it yeah yeah yeah would you
ever take a bath at a
hotel yeah really yeah okay that's Gro
yeah you wouldn't do it talk about human
soup or whatever I shower my jeans at a
hotel you're nuts I feel I feel like
even if it's a jacuzzi tub that's even
gross that's more soupy than you know
what he did we we recently on the road
me yeah they had the the the dispenser
in there he didn't never any shampoo he
just rinsed off for like 3 days didn't
use any soap straight up I shower twice
a day okay but one's just a rinse no
they were all rinses they were all just
rinses oh God it's a shower not a car
wash that's crazy Rin uh any vacations
you and Morgan uh go together yes when
we can and he'll come to the cool cities
that I go to gotcha yeah what where's
the the last nice vacation you guys went
on uh like just vacation or like there
was a show attached vacation which
doesn't happen a lot four Comics
Barcelona guessing two hot guys topless
in Barcelona I don't know why you're
topless but that's the vacation I'm
taking right now couple of champagne
coolies I like it zipping around on a
vesa yeah yeah I can't wait to go back
[__] nice you probably wear linen well
don't you I do yeah he wears it he wears
it better I know I can tell I can tell I
always wish I was a linen guy linen
pants and like a knit nice knit shirt
you guys go out to dinner F let's get
hot and be gay again it's crazy that
you're not the hot one I know literally
wait till I show you the picture it's
you're going to be why do you think I
keep bringing it up Joe the hell [__]
blue balling me over here man I wish I
could pull off linen I I look I look
like Captain wrinkles it's bad
dude reporting for Duty Shir your
shirt's all kind of half tucked stuff so
bad well you tuck in a shirt with like a
nice pair of nice pair of you're going
out to dinner nice pair of slacks tucked
in shirt uh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
I'm usually going to do like a nice
fitted t-shirt tucked in with a pair of
jeans and possibly a
Blazer nice classy yeah uh any baking
soda in the fridge at the house yeah
absolutely good in the freezer too no
not in the freezer but we did recently
bu my new favorite thing can I guess
please reverse osmosis water system know
what I have heard very specific
guest no thermonuclear accelerator what
the [__] no an appliance it is air fryer
no but not you're not an air fryer air
fryers are for people who can't cook how
you
doing Joe welcome to the show thank you
deep freezer and we bought a quarter
cow a lot of people are doing that we
bought a quarter cow and we went on a
Jesus Christ now as I say this [__] I'm
like are bougie grass-fed grass spin
organic but we bought it because we went
on a we're we're actually really big
fisherman we love to fish okay fly
freshwater salt water what are you doing
the end all of it across the board we
make trips to do it so we went to kuga
British Columbia it's like a really
remote part of BC and uh went on this
three-day fishing trip and came back
with our share of salmon and there was
we it was like almost 200 lbs of salmon
hibit and lingcod J and uh we had to get
a deep freezer you guys caught this
yourself wait till I show you the
picture how'd you get it back I don't
want to see the [__] picture before I
see your [__] hot hunk of a man wait
you caught fresh wild salmon yeah yeah
man that's probably so good you work for
butcher Box by any
chance I will accept the sponsorship but
yeah no we did it it was great and then
uh you stay there they take your fish
they clean it they put it in filets they
deep freeze it before you go give it to
you plain ready wow so okay it's all
right you guys are like every hack joke
about gay couples that are like they're
like we could just go fishing and blow
each other man like we
you want to be like serious about this
we're planning the wedding right now and
one of my things was is like oh [__] I'm
literally I came on this podcast I was
like no I think I am just garbage I
don't think I am um no we I wanted a
string Court you're wearing perfume
right now
dude I mean you're not
garbage I mean that's not a shot but
like you have a
scent okay which is Amazing by the way I
can't even really think straight I'm
slipping off my seat over here ready to
give you a jump then you throw fishing
into the mix I wanted a string quartet
at the cocktail party before the wedding
but I wanted him to play 90s rap and hip
hop in classical versions like bridon if
you've seen Bridgerton that's the music
in the background it's Ariana Grande
salt and pepper this and that did a
little research hopped on the phone with
this composer and I was like listen can
you compos listen listen listen listen I
go can you do this I don't know I kind
of wanted to be like Bridgerton if
you've ever heard of it and he goes yeah
I wrote the music I was like you're high
heard damn oh we have the guy from thec
show that's pretty good kind of crazy
right that's wild the own a George
Foreman grill no I was
kidding yeah totally I want a big
whatever you say Joe sorry sorry sorry
uh do you have any Coal's cash currently
no okay ever put your napkin over your
shirt when you wait but I love Co okay
but I do love I just don't like I they
would be like do you want to open no
yeah put a napkin over your shirt when
you eat no okay have you ever smoked a
Black and Mild yes okay how do you hold
a fork um
correctly you [__]
loser Toby eats everything with a
spoon man Bozo T-Bone I hope that camera
caught the pink Mist out of the back
back of your head [__] no I hold my Fork
right too I'm just curious mhm I don't
know if you do I've seen you I like that
no no no no no I do it like this with
the finger up top and then it goes right
hand knife left hand Fork right to the
mouth come on now do you e we with the
fork upside down Joe um sometimes I
don't think I have a preference but
sometimes on a steak perhaps yeah maybe
put a little mashed potato on it like
that no mashed potatoes this is where I
will lose fans and followers that's like
my CR I can't why I don't know goes
right to your hips what love potatoes
cook them any other way I'll eat it oh
you just don't like mashed po people
like is it the texture no it's just like
the dish I I can't I can't do it we were
so close to being perfect I know I know
you could have taught me how to
fish could have got some of that quarter
cow now did you and your uh fiance learn
were both of you just randomly fishermen
or were you something one of you brought
the other or you both got into fly
fishing is not something you just pick
up that's a skill our fourth date we
went ice fishing in uh hoton Lake in in
Michigan Jesus yeah and we just did it
we went but was that the first time were
you both fishermen or no yes you both
just we were like hey this is something
I like to do oh my God me too I going
I'm going ice fishing this week do you
want to yes wow yeah yeah yeah that's
nuts yep how many I can't even get my
wife to watch Seinfeld that's [__]
crazy dude you found another gay hot
fisherman like that honestly diamond in
the rough [__] right there yeah how many
times we use a towel at the house like
after a shower M three four okay that's
crazy we looked it up that's the exact
time is it really yeah speci yeah three
four yeah yeah if there's any scent that
like reminisces human it's out okay yeah
where do you hang that towel does it go
over the door over the back of the door
we need to redo our bathroom so we this
just it's really tight so if you just
used it it goes on the rack and then
whoever was on the rack and is now dry
hangs over the door so that when you get
in you know yours is on the door okay
you got a system there's a lot of
systems in our house I'm sure fabric
softener in a house not for me Morgan
does yes okay yeah I don't I don't like
what it does to the feel okay you use do
you use the B touch a microfiber cloth
like that feel like I can't touch cotton
balls see same Mak your blood run so
what you doing in the dryer just bear it
bear backing it yeah what kind of uh um
laundry to detergent this is where
Morgan and I differ Seattle creeped into
my brain so I have to use like the
dehydrated detergent sheets okay with no
plastic bottle and Morgan like can't get
off liquid detergent does he use the
good stuff or is he using like tide uh
I'm pretty sure it's tide really yeah
he's an every man okay can you play
acoustic guitar no okay you know how to
use chopsticks yes how do you feel about
the funion obsess D okay H we're back on
what do you call the remote the remote
okay everywhere of colored contacts
uh like in for
Halloween that's a pretty high in
Halloween C that's a classy an show you
the picture well this year nobody cuz I
was on tour and the special was coming
out but I went as Miss Frizzle one year
that's pretty good to for you to say
that's pretty good as an understatement
it was [__] amazing had my costume
made Jesus you you're going to look at
it and be like I'd [__] Miss Frizzle
like it's great I always kind of wanted
to from The Magic School Bus I don't
know that the magic scho Tomlin the
voice of Miss Frizzle The Magic School
Bus yeah oh it was a cartoon it was a
CTO that was your guys' [__] yeah I was
watching uh electric
company nobody electric company no all
right I'll go [__] myself you own
binoculars yes and a spotting scope
what's that for so we spot hunks dude
are you guys hun are you Hunters you can
see the Puget Sound from our living room
right so we look it's we do whale
watching from our living room whoa yeah
I mean this [__] guy comes pretty
cool yeah yeah yeah telescope we don't
have a telescope but Morgan's going to
die when he hears that why because he
just loves he has this ins joke with
friends about telescopes they love them
so we use our spotting scope cuz you can
look at the Moon with it too pretty cool
isn't it surpris his response wasn't
yeah
Hubble we rent Hubble we rent the James
web a couple times a year it's kind of
crazy H I like it you open your eyes
Under waterer in the pool yeah okay hot
tub never never never that's how you get
worms in your eyes maybe that's what's
wrong with my eyes um ever been to a
monster truck rally I have yeah I knew
that about you I have I have yes
especially as a a a young Tye growing up
in Michigan what's the mayonnaise
situation at the house um no preference
but it's what's the yellow litted one
helman's no Miracle Whip no Dukes yes
okay you're not using you're not use a
Miracle Whip no Miracle Whip aren't they
like dukes and Helman are like no no
helman's and then it's best something
helman's dukes and America's best or
whatever it is or America's I think
they're all the same either way that's
the classy the bad one is the is the um
Miracle Whip that's when you're trash no
no yeah but dukes and helmet are
different companies got you noted noted
will you eat over the sink yes when you
guys are having dinner together is it
always at the table were you sit in
front of the TV downstairs watching on
the couch we will sit at the table with
no TVs on no kidding something that I
don't do that I think you'll find
interesting Morgan got me up on this
[__] microwaves our plates before we eat
whoa what he warms heated plates they're
heated plates he microw
[__] this guy's a catch you have to wet
it or they just get hot this guy wore a
flannel shirt to like go undercover for
the
show I'm straight passing like it's no
even if we have friends over too
everyone's getting a heated plate no
[__] and a cold one for your salad yeah
whoa that's some [__] he got me on yeah
doing a salad course mhm yikes man long
way from Jets baby yeah I like it I'll
still throw down some Jets you would too
of course how do you feel about the
Coney Island
dog Lafayette or American is the
question Lafayette Cony Island
always now because it's Detroit thing
Detroit's freaking out it was the most
disgusting place you've ever been in
your life but the most amazing sensation
in your mouth and oh it's the best
they're Rivals right next to each other
like touching got it's like Pats and
Goos in Philly the but touching
touching touch too I mean literally not
touching but like as they're both on
point
they face each other yeah yeah they're
right next to
each to the door to American you're next
to the door damn too Lafayette it's nuts
ever been kicked out of a restaurant
never never will you leave a bad Yelp
review depends what happened a
yes yeah that's a yeah I bet it's very
viciously written may
conern you sold you served me a lukewarm
plate dear Cony Island dogs
I don't think that I've ever written a
bad Yelp review but I have called to
give my two cents but it was severe okay
I get it you go out to eat you guys get
a bottle of uh sparkling still or you
get tap water oh tap no preference yeah
don't need to go crazy uh okay well you
asked to change the table at a
restaurant no never no no no never never
unless maybe like if a guest is joining
us we weren't expecting I'll ask if they
can accommodate but no no no I finally
got the confidence it's a New York thing
too cuz esally in the win you to be by
the door right by the door you're I'm
sitting here eating in a Parker I will
go like can we you know is there another
table we have one season in Seattle and
there's no air conditioning anywhere cuz
you don't need it so
no you guys uh keep the butter on the
counter you keep it in the fridge uh
both I knew that was the [__] answer
I knew you can't bake with warm
sometimes you need it cold what's the
salt Himalayan uh it's so are you doing
Celtic you on Celtic yet we do we have a
dash a Celtic really have you ever read
the book Salt Fat acid heat it'll I mean
no but I know what you're talking about
it'll change your cooking life so non
iodine salt it's in a thing outside we
salt liberally it's a good situation
have you ever done gelato with olive oil
in the salt at the house no but I
wouldn't put it past
Morgan man Toby that was a great pull
that was a good one that's a classiest
thing I think ever came out of your
mouth I'm good for one or two or year
were you um close with your grand
grandparents uh all grandparents gone
except for one the year I was born the
one that was left was past when I was
probably in sixth grade so only a
childhood relationship what did you call
them uh
Juda okay there we go Grandpa was gone
there was Papa who was the Italian and
then Grandma okay it's not that I mean
who's juder juder was my dad's dad
polish okay yeah okay yeah I'll give you
that mhm all right that's not even
trashy man this kid have you ever had
aof Mike's Hard Lemonade absolutely
Fireball absolutely recently yes what
well what are you drinking when I go out
yeah you're going out not like a dinner
like well we're going to meet at this
regular bar for drinks I've learned the
hard way so I will go for like an
extremely light beer so I can continue
drinking for longer mhm pro move uh but
if I'm just going out for a few I'll do
like a manhatt
I like a Manhattan myself a Manhattan
sometimes a black Manhattan what's a
black Manhattan what's this liquor
that's made with like artichoke it's
like it's like black Lor it's made from
artichoke I forget the name that's not
Negron sambuka not s it's not like this
what you guys this round you're
in Bingo it's made with that and it's
just got a little Jing in it it's good
try it black Manhattan okay I love a
Manhattan what uh okay you going up you
going on the rocks with that uh so now
let's talk martinis too martinis for me
I I'm not doing a martini glass that's
the stupidest invention that ever
happened you have to be seated to have
that and then it's not even great the
best vodka in the world is blue shark
vodka they make it in Wilmington North
Carolina you can't get it many places if
I have the perfect cocktail it's going
to be um a dirty martini made with blue
shark vodka on the Rocks no fancy glass
blue cheese Olive really yeah slightly
slightly dirty wave the vermouth over
the glass okay yeah it's pretty good man
uh Amaro is yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah ah
yes I don't know it yes do what the last
time you had fast food do you eat
anything like that I don't really get
into fast food yeah it [__] me up whoa
okay wait okay okay okay do you consider
Jimmy John's fast food
Jimmy sandwich yeah but shout out to
them yeah yeah like at Jimmy johnes and
turquoise jewelry no wait have you ever
gotten but honestly that was a hate
crime have you ever that's really funny
have you ever gotten the day old bread
from Jimmy Johns yeah oh yeah yeah you
make crout tons with it really yeah go
to Jimmy John's and get the day old
bread I'll go there but if I happen to
be there and they have the day old bread
and I know I'm serving that night I'll
make croutons out of that bread that's I
mean we got to wrap this that's [__]
nuts [__] taking garbage turn it into
into [__] croutons wait you're saying
that's trashy oh that's classy I was
going to say he's serving that evening
he's having guests over I know with the
chilled with the chilled [__] plates
and the hot
plates we we wouldn't get past the front
door at that joint you would we family
absolutely TOS thought I ever see a
UFO yes and recently twice hit me so we
did discover what it was but this is the
second time anyone's ever said yes with
my
I was with my future mother-in-law and
we were in North Carolina on the beach
and we saw this string no the first time
it happened we were on my porch okay we
saw this string of lights uniformly
spaced out we were freaking out we're
like oh my God oh my God they're here
everybody saw it we're like holy [__]
holy [__] holy [__] when I came down I
was like okay if that was as intense as
it was other people saw it and it's
definitely googleable by now I looked it
up and it was just like the starlink the
Elon Musk on he's been getting a lot of
people with that goddamn thing for
when's he turning that on by the way so
when we saw a second time same looking
thing and then we convinced my future
sister-in-law that it was aliens we're
like oh my God what is that crazy that
is identified oh my God is so perfect
and crazy right over the ocean play
trick on a sister-in-law I respect it
the whole family they're uh I'm coming
into a amazing family that's good for
you man it's [__] awesome I mean this
guy's [__] all class like probably
the classiest one of the classiest
people we've ever had on the show 100%
down the line yeah what are you talking
about oh my God you've had some zingers
on I'm shocked right now that's wild
yeah like I said you have a scent that
you won't tell us what it is that's like
you're playing defense on your smell dud
A and A mysterious fiance who warms up
the plates in the microwave you're
putting Ranch on pizza but it's famous
Ranch oh God I am yeah we got you
garbage no all class baby you're all
class babyk congratulations
congratulations on the special don't eat
the cray out on YouTube right now Joe
dumbrowski check it out on tour anything
else you want the folks out there to
know watch it like it comment and on do
the whole thing it's on YouTube let them
know the army of garbage came to [__]
comment you know hear from a let know I
would love that I would love that thank
guys man this was a fun one Kippy what
do you got for him guys we're all over
the road uh tours winding down in Philly
to shows at the Filmore that's [__]
there's like maybe 200 tickets left to
the second show get those let's go scoop
them up get those [__] tickets it's
going to sell out don't make me look bad
in front of Patty should be bitching at
me thank you so much for everything guys
gang we love you Joe we love you
congratulations buddy we'll see you next
week peace peace